Okay, so let's do a little exploring and think about the
mechanics of this problem. The first thing I'd like to know, is
how do I go about requesting the data I want from this
website? Again, I'm thinking about how I get to a point where
I can actually do this programmatically. So most web browsers give
you the ability to actually inspect individual elements of a webpage, so
in this case, let's just take a look at that selector. And
if we do that, we can see all of the options right
here in the HTML for the page. And based on
our understanding of HTML, we know that it's these values here
that we would need to submit as part of our post
request. Alright, the options for airports look very similar. So instead
of looking at that, let's take a look at The data
that's here. Now, a couple things that I want to point out
here, before we actually look at the HTML again. One is
that for any given airport, this is reporting both domestic and
international flights for that airport. Now in my case, I'm not actually
interested in that distinction. I simply want to know arrivals and departures.
So where does value in both columns, for a given month? I'm
simply going to add them together. So this is one place that
I'm doing a little bit of reshaping of the data. It's also
the case that I've got these totals here in this columns, and
then at the end of the rows for any given year. I'm
simply going to ignore those. Again, a little bit of reshaping. Okay.
So let's take a look at these elements. Now as you
might expect, these are laid out in a table, and if
I scroll to the top, I can actually see there's a
class attribute for this particular table here. And this is going to help
me when it comes time to actually parse this HTML in
order to extract the data. So we've looked at, both how to
go about getting the values we're going to need to submit
in a post request in order to get the data we need.
And then we've looked at once that data is presented to us, or
in this case, to our program that's going to be accessing the site.
How do we go about finding that data and pulling that data out
of the HTML? Or at least where is it located in the HTML file?